in this press briefing today the
president insisting
a story alleging he has called americans
killed in battle
losers and suckers is fake news in his
words
the atlantic uses statements from
unnamed sources
in a very detailed story several people
in the trump circle as you just heard
there are saying on the record
the allegations are false while other
unnamed sources
are adding more context and background
and we'll lay it all out for you tonight
meantime joe biden calls the reported
comments from the president disgusting
and said today quote if true it proves
he is not fit to be commander in chief
let's begin tonight with chief white
house correspondent john roberts live
on the north lawn good evening john
brent good evening to you this story is
about an incident that is almost two
years old now the president's trip to
france back in 2018
to commemorate veterans day and how the
dark clouds that mark that trip
continue to swirl above the president's
head
president trump was incensed today about
a report in the atlantic magazine
that claimed in november 2018 the
president said he was canceling a visit
to the ainmar
american military cemetery in france
because the war dead interred there
were losers and suckers now there's
nobody that considers the military and
especially
people that have given their lives in
the military to me they're heroes
the official reason for calling off the
visit was bad weather it was raining
low clouds and marine one couldn't fly
in an email the president's military aid
writing
team we are a bad weather call for
today's lift chief of staff general
kelly will replace potus for today's
ceremony
please advise if any questions while the
president could have taken a motorcade
out to the cemetery
there were security concerns about being
so far out in the country
and the president was said to not be
eager to sit in the car for the four
hour round trip
former national security advisor john
bolton was in a meeting
to discuss whether the president should
make the trip john bolton
no friend of mine but he wrote a book
and he talks about this incident
and he doesn't mention it bolton told
fox news this afternoon
he never heard the president mention
suckers or losers
in relation to u.s war dead i didn't
hear
either of those comments or anything
even resembling them i was there at the
point in time that morning when it was
decided that uh
that he would not go to on mars cemetery
he decided not to do it because of john
kelly's recommendation it was entirely a
weather related decision
and i thought the proper thing to do two
other former aides who were in the
meeting confirmed the same thing to fox
news
good afternoon folks in wilmington today
joe biden indicated he didn't know the
veracity of the claims in the article
but ripped the president anyways if
these statements are true
the president should humbly apologize
to every gold star mother and father
and every blue star family that he's
denigrated and sold it
who the heck does he think he is
president trump did get some good news
today the economy added nearly 1.4
million more jobs in august
the unemployment rate dropping from 10.2
to 8.4 percent
beating expectations the president tried
to hang on to the one
issue where he continues to lead his
opponent you're going to see
tremendous growth in the very near
future
we're rounding the curve we're coming up
with vaccines i think the vaccines are
going to be announced very soon
on the visit to i'm on cemetery aides
warned the president
at the time that canceling the trip
would not play well politically
particularly when other world leaders
like canada's prime minister justin
trudeau
and german chancellor angela merkel were
making trips via motorcade out to
various cemeteries around paris
i was on that trip and remember that the
political fallout from the cancellation
was particularly harsh right all right
john stand by if you would